Today we're going to talk about the
Democratic People's Republic of Korea.
The only country in the wells named
quite say,
ironically,
you may know it's better as North Korea,
it sounds democratic as they come
through,
ruled by the same family for 70 years,
can be the head of state has been
inherited through three generations of
the Kim family and Kim Il Sung,
Kim Jong Il ams.
Now Kim Jong own ends in keeping with
this publicly democratic tradition,
the leader of North Korea is called not
president or not king,
but supremely supremely up.
You know,
just like any normal democracy.
So welcome.
We really sat on North Korea that you
haven't had before.
Well,
it is one of the most brutal
dictatorships in the whole wells when
mass torture,
execution and extreme poverty are
common.
And now you might ask,
well,
why did we cast so much about this
country?
Well,
the answer to that is as simple as
nuclear bombs.
This is a country that is still
officially at war with South Korea and
it makes a pastime of threatening Japan
and the US with nuclear annihilation.
And while that might have sounded
farfetched at one point in time with
nuclear tests happening almost every
other year,
people are starting to take a little old
Kim,
a bit more serious
sleep.
You still might wonder if North Korea is
that dangerous?
Well,
why isn't anyone stopping them?
they actually tried basically every
sanction you could think of hasn't been
thrown at North Korea bus.
Instead of that financial pressure
forcing reform North Korea has just had
it's diplomats selling meth out of their
embassies well worldwide to shortlist
there.
Yes,
indeed.
That on North Korean embassies and two,
yes indeed they were selling drugs out
of them.
But there's one country that still calls
North Korea,
uh,
friends.
And that country is China.
They even have a treaty called the Sino,
North Korea and mutual aid and
cooperation.
Friendship Treaty,
China and North Korea are as close to
each other as lips are two teeth,
China.
And to a lesser extent,
Russia have been the only things
propping up the North Korean regime.
So that must give China a lot of sway
over the Kim Jong Rights.
While that's what the international
community thought that south China came
to be seen as the only country in the
world could turn in order to reign in
North Korea's nuclear ambitions as well,
not so fast because things are changing
in China is starting to get a rather
annoyed at that little brothers Tom
foolery.
So the question today is,
what's behind the cooling relationship
between China and North Korea and what
consequences could this have on the
future of the country?
Joining us today to answer these
questions is the biggest China expert on
youtube.
Yes.
We are talking about Chris Chapple,
the host of China or uncensored
Hello Simon and hello to all our friends
at visual politic.
So relationship between these two
communists.
Brothers have deteriorated so much in
China and North Korea are in the middle
of a war of work.
Basically China said that it would work
with the evil imperialists.
You know the US do combat North Korea's
nuclear program.
Then North Korean state run media
responded that China should really think
about how it's reckless act of chopping
down the pillar of North Korea.
China relations could have grave
consequences.
And then Johnny state run media
responded with a not so subtle threat to
end their alliance.
So why is that the.
Are they stabbing each other in the
back?
But we're going to have a look at that
right now.
China North Korea showing that ends up
North Korea really make the perfect best
friends.
They have much in common.
They share a border.
They both had communist uprisings,
ams,
they have installed leaders who have
radical views of Marxism.
The People's Republic of China,
ends of the Democratic People's Republic
of Korea.
Really all like the Quintin Tarantino
and Robert Rodriguez on international
politics.
Especially like if you're doing a movie
or something.
Doing it with Robert is just the idea
that that's a year I get to hang out
with Robert.
Now
China does more than just give North
Korea financial aid.
Jen has also made big loans of the North
Korean regime so they can build
railroads and highways and they're
pretty forgiving when p young can't pay
back its debt.
And then there's oil.
For decades,
China was the main source of dino juice
to North Korea.
There's military
great
help train North Korean hackers,
hackers who've now become a threat to
the international community,
including China.
What does Beijing get in exchange?
Well,
North Korea is a cheap labor paradise.
In fact,
in many products with the made in China,
labels should actually say,
made in DPR.
Okay,
brilliant sportswear brand.
Rip Curl made a public apology this week
afterward emerged that some of it's
skier had been made in one of North
Korea.
Stayed on factor,
but hold on a minute because things are
starting to change.
The Chinese Communist Party today is a
little less interested in the global
spread of communism and then there's one
more interested in becoming a global
superpower.
North Korea is well,
very rarely cramping China's style.
Imagine how hard it is to be cool with
America when you're good.
Buddy North Korea keeps threatening to
blow them up,
but this is the end of the story.
Sixty years ago,
China and North Korea were pretty
similar,
but today things are quite different.
Terrorists came to see closely is the
misery experienced by the North Korean
neighbors.
I'm not old,
but I feel like what I can see over
there is similar to the very difficult
time that our nation had in the past,
a loss of North Korean citizens would do
whatever it takes in order to cross the
Chinese borden and Beijing is scared of
what could become a refugee crisis
similar to that of Syria.
If this wasn't enough,
Pyongyang's diplomacy hasn't been all
that diplomatic with its own allies.
Here's a little snub courtesy of Kim
Jong Un in 2015
in all female North Korean pop band
formed by leader Kim Jong Un abruptly
canceled a Beijing concert on Saturday
and headed back home to Pyongyang,
but unfortunately it February 2017
became the breaking points for this
friendship.
North Korea launching some ballistic
missiles or conducting some nuclear
tests is nothing new,
but what is do is the degree to which
China is willing to criticize it.
This is happening at a time when Chinese
leader Xi Jingping is trying to improve
his relationship with the United States
and of course,
according to young.
This is a stab in the back,
triggered the war of words between these
two countries with state run media in
both countries criticizing the other,
but again,
this is not the end of the story.
Remember those Chinese trains?
North Korean hackers,
there's allegedly hit several Hollywood
studios two years ago.
Well,
if you lay down with dogs,
don't be surprised if you wake up with
fleas
called ransomware attacks that began
Friday.
Have struck China hard.
If North Korea is responsible,
even unintentionally,
it wouldn't be the first known attempt
by Pyong Young to digitally Pilfer
China's coffers at such a scale.
In other words,
buying,
keeping things the same.
North Korea is about to lose their
biggest ally,
the only country willing to defend them
in case of war.
This is a war even if just for
propaganda reasons.
A lot of people would love to start.
Hey,
trump,
come in.
I know what you're thinking.
Oh,
Simon,
this.
This is quite a story and need some
needs to become a true visual politic
video.
So well,
no.
Russia has already taken over the supply
of jet fuel to North Korea after China
halted exports two years ago.
According to the industry sources in
China,
Russia and North Korea also have a lot
of things in common apart from sharing a
border.
They both have strong,
attractive and manly lead.
Both countries.
Human rights are considered optional.
Russia and North Korea just started a
ferry service that connects their two
countries to Russian companies can be
regularly stock with a North Korean
slave workforce.
Does that mean Putin and Kim are now
besties?
Well,
so fast
because Kim Jong Un has a rather funny
concept of truth.
No,
rhea launches a missile near Russians.
Alright,
listen,
Kim Jong Un dude.
This is really not the way you made
friends and as you might imagine with
things like this,
Russia may not be too big to become a
north.
Korea is unconditional allied and so for
the first time in its history,
the most hated country.
It has run out of allies and this is
where donald trump's steps into the vic
trap.
We have a big problem.
We have somebody that is not doing the
right thing,
and that's going to be my
responsibility.
This comes at a time when China is
trying to work on a new trade deal with
the United States at the same time that
Donald trump is facing a lot of
pressure.
Hi.
So the question is now,
will Donald Trump be taking
responsibility for North Korea to
improve his image in the United States?
Could this be the end of the North
Korean dictatorship?
Well,
you can leave us your thoughts in the
comments section below.
We'd love to hear from you.
Meanwhile,
if you want to know all about the
details of the breakup between China and
North Korea,
don't forget to check out my channel.
China uncensored
China runs sensitive,
certainly the best channel about
politics in China on Youtube,
and it's really worth subscribing to if
you haven't already.
So please do head over to that channel.
Check out,
best off and do something
skype.
If you haven't done it yet,
we also hope that you think we are worth
subscribing to you.
So please do hit that subscribe button
below this video.
And if you did like this video,
give us a thumbs up as always.
I'll see you next time.